I will say
that when you come on the Pod or even
when I just get to hang with you it's I
I laugh myself sick I get I'm sore from
laughing at the stuff you do and it's so
much fun to be around you whether we're
recording it or not and I'm remembering
now I had this party at my house and you
showed up and
he we hadn't even created each other yet
there's a bunch of people there at some
holiday party and you show up over my
shoulder and you're a I want to remember
this right a Germanic guy from the late
19th century who had you immediately
said this you laid it out immediately
and I knew exactly what it was but you
just came up to me and used you uh
you'll remember what it was I think but
a guy from the late 19th century in
Germany who had fought me in a duel over
a woman and lost but now you're putting
a brave face on and you and your arm
doesn't work because of the dueling and
you walk up to me and you were you were
congratulating me on my house and my
wife and trying to put a brave face on
it all but seething with resentment yeah
very nice O'Brien
yeah it seems like you've done very well
for yourself
I see ya
and you would say oh this is my son you
know and I go huh
you have a son yeah
with the woman that you know yeah
I I see well I appreciated the invite
home Brian I was all right I'll say I
was quite
surprised to get it
and you were like well it's nice that
you I think you said it was nice that
you drove here I go flew I flew here
right
we could try to kick that as long as you
can and then yeah eventually someone's
like will you guys please stop well that
is the nature of this uh yes yeah please
stop that but yeah but I was so happy
because you know rather than oh hey
thanks for having me over place looks
great this is a really good ham
it's someone I fought in a duel in
Germany and I maimed yeah yeah and I won
the woman that he loved and he's putting
a good face on it yeah it was very stiff
upper lip yeah very yeah and immediately
yeah stoic and uh maimed
position now
I think he just turned around I was like
well
very good O'Brien I see you've got a
very nice house here and he went oh oh I
I'm surprised you know I was like yes I
was very surprised to get the uh
the invitation of Ryan yeah and then I
think you mentioned since how do since I
do right
it all came out yeah and then it was
like yes someone would hand you
something like this is the only um that
works dear thank you very much
I would love a tuna stick or whatever it
is
yes I just was laughing just a bit but
you know who who likes those those bits
of the old school bits like that at
those parties uh is Larry David yeah
yeah and oh my god when you get him
laughing it is he really gives it up
it's like surprising when people go
what's Larry David like I'm like he is a
laugher with hellofresh you get Farm
Fresh yeah pre-portion ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep that's huge I need
pre-portioned I know me too because my
portions are out of control yeah I get
too much of something and then it just
goes bad and starts rotting yeah well
you should learn to use the refrigerator
anyway
trips to the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and get this affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit
exclamation point now sonnet you've used
hello fresh I have used hello fresh
you've cooked up some nice meals for
attack that's your husband yes I have
and you know what I like about it is
that it does come all in one one box
it's very it's stuff I would never
normally cook on my own and it have
everything you could possibly need in
you know when you're making a recipe and
it's like I'm gonna make clams Alfredo
yeah and you've got everything and then
you get to the very end I don't have the
clams oh no that's the worst well that
doesn't happen with hellofresh
I know go to hellofresh.com teamcoco16
use code team coco16 for 16 free meals
plus free shipping that's hellofresh.com
steam coco16. America's number one meal
kit he laughs so hard at stuff yeah also
have you noticed that when Larry laughs
his jaw goes like a skeleton like yeah
it's is it like if you just started
yanking on the court of a ventriloquist
jumping up and down
that's his laugh and it's kind of crazy
but because his character is such a
crank you don't get to see him lose it
but I had an experience where Dana
Carvey famously does this thing I
absolutely love we both are obsessed
we're both obsessed with it uh and and
and he's done it here I believe where he
uh he's Jimmy Stewart and he's in a car
with Catherine Hepburn he's trying to
talk her uh into uh pleasuring him and
um but he also has very specific needs
about you know how it should how I want
you to act surprised when I take it out
but not too surprised and he's very
bossy about it and it's you're crying
when you hear it so Larry I'm talking to
Larry and I do it for him I said this is
Dana's thing and I do it for him and he
was laughing as hard as I've seen him
he's gonna die because his his jaw is
and so then I see him a couple of days
later I run into him and he went oh my
God
I was at this party
and uh Bill Hader did Dana's thing and
it's the hardest I've laughed and I said
what you Larry yeah no that wasn't a
party that was my party and I yeah I was
doing it for you and he was like well it
seemed like hater it was really funny no
he no I think what happened was also was
that you do the Jimmy Stewart thing and
the thing I do of Dana's which again is
a Dana bit yep is the Bert Lancaster and
Kirk Douglas having sex
that's what I was doing
and so when I would do that which again
is Dana's bit we're all doing Dana's
we're all doing Dana's bit but when Dana
Carvey did that for me once and I I fell
on the ground I was yeah or just a
couple of fellas yeah
you know please just a little more
please
don't worry now yeah and I think I want
you to take it slow
and then the line that I always remember
was don't around now I don't have a
lot of play down there
and he
it is an old Dana Carvey bit but when he
he did that I just when he came he
hosted when I was a cast member at SNL
and when he hosted it did become a thing
where I would just ask him well could
you do this or you could I mean I was
just following him around like yeah a a
puppy dog I was doing all the stuff that
you know asking and asking about you
know Phil Hartman's stories and you know
everything you know that was the thing
well he is
um fortunately that that nice combo of
one of the funniest people ever and also
incredibly nice unbelievable and kind
and uh probably to a fault people
pleaser but yeah we took Dana out to uh
lunch we were here at the studios and
then we went we did something and then
we went next door to get lunch and a
couple of writers came along
he put on a a show for the writers and
it very naturally but just was going
through all kinds of stuff and and he
was doing uh Henry Fonda oh and uh it
was so
funny and afterwards the writers were
thinking you know there's that Dynamic
that you hear about where the comedian
is
funny on stage but then
if you see them off stage they're quite
yeah they can be quite dour and
um you see that a bunch of times and
then there are these people that just
nope yeah they just snatch them on an
airplane and uh my wife and I once got
on an airplane and someone behind us was
like kind of heckling me and talking
about oh they'll let the Irish on this
plane and I guess they'll let any skunk
what what the airline was it Air Lingus
yeah that was the part that shocked me
yeah almost to this Airline it's like
welcome to the fair line
but it was um sitting right behind us
was Don Rickles oh my God and Don
Rickles was and then the whole flight
like cross country was Don Rickles just
peppering me with insults but then
telling great Show Business stories and
it was one of the highlights of my life
you know oh man I still I watched his
stuff on YouTube all the time him on
Carson him on all that stuff I mean is
did you ever see the one where he's on
Letterman with uh Denzel Washington next
to him oh my god do yourself a favor
it's so just that that he was that age I
mean he was really old and when he'd be
on your show
I mean he was hilarious he's so fast
it's so fast so insanely fast also he
had this knowledge of you know we all
know there's this like weird line
between music and comedy where somehow
they're just things that sound funny and
they work and you don't know why and one
of the things he discovered was someone
would say something he'd be like that's
right you know like almost as if to say
you know what do you want to clap on the
back and she said what do you want a
cookie yeah what do you want a cookie or
he said David Letterman goes uh uh Frank
Sinatra's wife's name is Barbara and uh
your your wife's name is Barbara right
and he goes what are you a detective
he goes what kind of what's up with
these what kind of questions
he goes off on that question and just
zeros in on and he's like you make a
billion dollars a year and you ask the
most stupid question and I yeah it's the
best drop your pants and fire a rocker
yeah oh my God if you can find him with
Dick Cavett in the early 70s It's really
because Dick cavett's trying to give it
to him like oh I like your act but I
always did like Jackie Leonard you know
what I mean and he's like oh all right
you know yeah oh you really want to oh
you wanna walk around a karate fight
yeah it was like okay Bruce Lee it's
like all right cool and then it's
fascinating to watch it's on YouTube
it's really interesting where you could
just tell he has zero zero respect for
him